[Musik]
>> SALLY: Für die Teigkruste verwende ich
ein Päckchen Baklava-Teig,
50 Gramm Butter.
Und für die Nussmischung brauche ich jeweils 50 Gramm
Walnüsse,
Haselnüsse,
Mandeln,
Pistazien,
50 Gramm braunen Zucker
und etwas Zimt.
Schön den Rand der Form bestreichen,
damit die Yufka-Blätter gleich daran haften.
Jetzt nehmt ihr die Teigblätter.
Und die sind wirklich ganz, ganz, ganz dünn!
Ihr könnt sie auch gerne auseinanderreißen.
Immer mal wieder Butter reinstreichen.
Und so forme ich jetzt die Tortenkruste.
Der Boden wird jetzt so erst mal vorgebacken.
Und ich kann in der Zwischenzeit die Nussfüllung vorbereiten.
Die Nüsse werde ich jetzt grob hacken.
Dann kommen sie hier auf den Herd
und werden bei mittelhoher Hitze geröstet.
Jetzt kommt hier etwas Zimt dazu
und der braune Zucker.
Dann ziehe ich die karamellisierten Nüsse vom Herd herunter.
Das lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen
und kann schon mal die Cheesecake-Masse zubereiten.
Für die Cheesecake-Füllung verwende ich
500 Gramm Frischkäse in Doppelrahmstufe,
100 Gramm Sahnejoghurt,
40 Gramm Stärke,
40 Gramm Honig,
100 Gramm Zucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
vier Eier
und den Saft und die Schale einer Zitrone.
Zuerst nehme ich jetzt den Frischkäse.
Den verrühre ich ganz kurz,
damit er klümpchenfrei wird.
Der Joghurt bringt so eine leichte Säure,
eine schöne Frische mit rein.
Kurz verrühren.
Jetzt gebe ich hier einfach noch die restlichen Zutaten mit rein,
also etwas Vanilleextrakt,
Stärke,
etwas Honig,
dann Zucker,
Eier.
Und jetzt nehme ich nur ein kleines bisschen Zitronenabrieb,
eine ganz kleine Prise wirklich.
Und jetzt einfach noch ein bisschen Zitronensaft mit dazu.
Und jetzt schön langsam rühren.
Jetzt gebe ich die Nüsse erst mal
auf den Teigboden.
Da kommt jetzt die Cheescake-Masse vorsichtig drüber.
Jetzt ganz vorsichtig bis zum Rand streichen.
Und dann bei 130°C in den Backofen,
sodass die Masse schön langsam stockt.
Jetzt kommt hier noch die Sahneschicht drauf.
Für die Creme nehme ich 200 Gramm Sahne,
100 Gramm Schmand,
30 Gramm Puderzucker,
etwas Vanilleextrakt
und San-apart.
Jetzt nehme ich zuerst den Schmand.
Der kommt hier in die Schüssel
und wird jetzt gemeinsam mit der Sahne verrührt.
Vanilleextrakt noch rein.
Dann Puderzucker.
Und ein bisschen verrühren
und dann mit San-apart steifschlagen.
Die Creme gebe ich jetzt hier oben drauf.
Ich meine, ihr könnt den Cheesecake auch so lassen.
Aber ich finde eine weiße Creme als Abschluss echt schön.
Jetzt ganz vorsichtig glatt streichen.
Und jetzt nehme ich hier noch die Nüsse,
die ich zurückgelegt habe,
und die streue ich jetzt hier noch
über den Rand.
Und dann kommt die Torte noch mal in den Kühlschrank
für etwa ein bis zwei Stunden,
bis sie richtig schön durchkühlt.
Und dann probieren wir.
Der Kuchen ist jetzt schön kalt.
Jetzt ziehe ich ihn samt der Backfolie
direkt auf meine Platte.
[Musik]
Für den Zuckersirup verwende ich
300 Milliliter Wasser,
300 Gramm Zucker,
– da nehme ich jetzt einen Kokosblütenzucker –
eine Stange Zimt,
200 Gramm Honig
und einen Spritzer Zitronensaft.
Ich gebe jetzt hier den Kokosblütenzucker in einen Topf.
Zimtstange auch.
Wasser dazu.
Und auch Honig.
Und jetzt einfach so lange einkochen lassen,
bis der Sirup, wenn man ihn heruntertropfen lässt,
wie ein Faden läuft.
Jetzt ist der Sirup soweit.
Ich habe jetzt den Herd bereits ausgestellt.
Jetzt lasse ich ihn wirklich komplett abkühlen,
nehme nach etwa fünf Minuten die Zimtstange raus.
Ansonsten wird das Aroma zu intensiv.
Hier gebe ich jetzt noch den Spritzer Zitronensaft dazu.
Und dann lasse ich jetzt den Sirup komplett abkühlen.
Für die Füllung verwende ich
250 Gramm Haselnüsse,
30 Gramm Kakaopulver, ungesüßt,
einen Teelöffel Zimt,
etwas Tonkabohne,
eine Prise Salz,
50 Gramm Kakaonibs.
Zum Bestreichen brauche ich Butter
Und natürlich die Baklava-Blätter.
Ich nehme jetzt zuerst die Butter.
Die habe ich extra in so einer Emailleform.
Die darf nämlich auch auf den Herd.
Dann kurz schmelzen lassen.
Dann die Nussfüllung.
Dafür gebe ich jetzt schon mal
den Zimt in eine große Schüssel.
Dann etwas Salz dazu
und Tonkabohne.
Davon immer nur ganz wenig nehmen!
Wie bei der Muskatnuss.
Dann kommt hier das Kakaopulver mit rein.
Und ich nehme zusätzlich noch Kakaonibs.
Das gibt dem Ganzen noch einen schönen Crunch.
So.
Hier kommen jetzt noch die Nüsse mit dazu.
Huch!
Die werde ich jetzt vorher selber mahlen.
[Musik]
Ich habe jetzt hier meine Glasauflaufform.
Ihr solltet jetzt auf jeden Fall eine Form nehmen,
die dicht ist.
Und hier die Baklava-Blätter.
Jetzt lege ich die Form hier drauf
– ich glaube, so passt es ganz gut –
und schneide das jetzt hier zu.
Jetzt die Form mit der Butter bestreichen.
Hier kommt jetzt
die erste Schicht rein.
Da nehme ich gleich so zwei, drei Blätter.
Dann kommt zwischenrein
immer mal wieder ein bisschen Butter.
Und ich lege jetzt in etwa die Hälfte der Blätter rein
und zwischenrein auch den Verschnitt.
Jetzt kommt hier die Nussfüllung rein.
Jetzt kommen hier einfach noch
die übrigen Teigschichten drauf,
auch mit der Butter dazwischen.
Schön alles abdecken.
Und jetzt einfach die restliche Butter
einmal komplett auf die Oberfläche geben.
Und dann wird das jetzt gleich geschnitten,
bevor es gebacken wird.
Nach dem Backen ist es nämlich zu knusprig.
Und ich schneide es jetzt gleich in Dreiecke.
Also erst mal Rechtecke schneiden
und dann Dreiecke.
Beim Schneiden einfach immer nur darauf achten,
nicht sägen und auch kein Sägemesser nehmen,
sondern ein schönes, glattes,
und wirklich nur nach unten schneiden,
also einmal durchhacken sozusagen.
Jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen Restbutter.
Die kommt hier noch oben drauf.
Und dann kommt es in den Backofen
und darf richtig knusprig gebacken werden.
Aber, wie gesagt, ihr müsst sicherstellen,
dass der Zuckersirup schon richtig gut abgekühlt ist.
Jetzt ist das Baklava gebacken!
Und jetzt den abgekühlten Sirup
ganz vorsichtig darüberfließen lassen.
Wenn ihr möchtet, dann könnt ihr das Baklava
vor dem Servieren noch mit Schokolade übergießen.
Dafür habe ich einfach 50 Gramm Zartbitterkuvertüre gehackt,
zwei Drittel davon über dem warmen Wasserbad erwärmt
und dann kommt da ein halber Teelöffel Kokosfett dazu.
Ihr könnt es dann vom Herd herunternehmen.
Dann das restliche Drittel einrühren.
Und schon ist die Kuvertüre temperiert.
[Musik]
Für mein Helva brauche ich
200 Gramm Butter,
450 Gramm Mehl,
200 Gramm Puderzucker,
300 Gramm Sesampaste, also Tahin,
Vanilleextrakt
und Pistazien.
Das Helva wird jetzt ganz traditionell im Topf zubereitet.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt die Butter
und kann sie erst einmal vorsichtig schmelzen lassen.
Jetzt kann ich hier vorsichtig das Mehl einrühren.
Und daraus wird so eine Art Mehlschwitze gemacht.
Und jetzt wird diese Mehlschwitze so lange angebraten,
bis sie so leicht bräunlich wird
und bis auch der Mehlgeschmack verschwindet.
Jetzt kommt der Puderzucker dazu
und wird auch noch kurz eingerührt.
Jetzt kann ich die Masse vom Herd herunternehmen.
Jetzt kommt nämlich
das Tahin rein, also die Sesampaste.
Und jetzt so lange rühren,
bis die Klümpchen verschwunden sind.
Und, wer möchte, kann einen Teil davon mit Kakao verrühren
für eine Kakaovariante.
Dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach etwas Kakao
und verrühre das mit dem Tahin
und färbe dann etwa ein Drittel davon damit ein.
Bei mir kommen jetzt hier die Pistazien noch rein.
Hier auch welche.
Jetzt kommt die Masse in eine Form rein
und wird dann gepresst,
damit sie später schön rausgestürzt werden kann.
Ihr könnt jetzt zum Beispiel auch so ein Glas verwenden,
einfach eine Form eurer Wahl.
Ich verwende jetzt hier eine Kastenform
und habe die mit Frischhaltefolie ausgekleidet,
damit ich das später auch wieder rausbekomme.
Und jetzt kommt ein bisschen von der hellen Masse rein,
dann von der dunklen Masse.
Und dann kann ich das ein bisschen vermischen.
Und jetzt lasse ich es so abgedeckt
bei Zimmertemperatur abkühlen.
Und dann kommt es noch mal
für zwei Stunden in den Kühlschrank.
[Musik]
Ich mache heute ein Zusammenspiel aus Cannoli
und dem türkischen Künefe.
Künefe ist das hier jetzt aber nicht.
Diese Teigfäden, die heißen Kadayif.
Ich bereite jetzt hier erst mal das Engelshaar vor.
Und zwar zupft ihr das ganz vorsichtig auseinander.
Ich ziehe jetzt hier die Teigstränge ganz vorsichtig auseinander.
Ich nehme jetzt hier eine Hörnchenform.
Jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die Butter,
bestreicht die Form damit.
Jetzt einen langen Teigstreifen nehmen.
Den ersten hier unten so ein bisschen befestigen
und dann von oben nach unten
schön dicht aufrollen.
Und dann gerne einfach den nächsten nehmen,
noch mal daran setzen
und so dicht wie möglich aufrollen.
Anschließend dann mit der Butter bestreichen.
Die gibt dem Ganzen noch mal ein bisschen Form
und natürlich auch Geschmack.
Jetzt hier noch mal schön mit Butter bestreichen.
Und, sobald sich die Teigfäden vollgesaugt haben
mit der Butter, lassen sie sich auch besser formen.
Also dann drücke ich sie noch mal
an dem Hörnchen schön fest.
Ich wasche jetzt kurz meine Hände
und schiebe die schon mal in den Backofen,
sodass sie wirklich schön goldbraun geröstet werden,
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
auch schon mal den Zuckersirup machen.
Für den Zuckersirup verwende ich
150 Gramm Zucker,
75 Gramm Wasser,
einen Spritzer Zitronensaft
und einen Teelöffel Rosenwasser.
Und hier gebt ihr jetzt einfach alle Zutaten in den Topf.
Also erst Zucker und Wasser
lasse ich jetzt aufkochen.
Und den Zuckersirup bereitet man immer so zu,
dass der einfach schön abkühlen kann.
Deswegen mache ich den jetzt direkt.
Jetzt kocht der Sirup.
Da gebe ich jetzt einen Spritzer Zitronensaft dazu
und für den Geschmack ein bisschen Rosenwasser.
Jetzt lasse ich ihn einfach nur zwei, drei Minuten köcheln,
bis er
am Faden herunterläuft.
Den Sirup lasse ich jetzt abkühlen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal die Zitronencreme zubereiten.
Für die Zitronencreme verwende ich
50 Gramm Zitronensaft,
70 Gramm Zucker,
250 Gramm Mascarpone,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
300 Gramm Sahne
und San-apart.
Die Mascarpone
– ihr könnt aber auch Frischkäse nehmen –
kurz verrühren.
Dann Puderzucker dazu.
Dann langsam die Sahne dazu geben.
Mit Zitronensaft verfeinern.
Vanilleextrakt nicht vergessen!
Und mit San-apart steifschlagen.
Und jetzt einfach die Creme in einen Spritzbeutel füllen
mit einer Sterntülle zum Beispiel.
Hier ist jetzt ein Spritzbeutel echt empfehlenswert.
Denn die Hörnchen lassen sich ansonsten
wirklich sehr schwer nur füllen.
Jetzt nehme ich die abgekühlten Hörnchen ganz vorsichtig,
setze sie schon mal auf meinen Servierteller
und vorsichtig das Hörnchen rausziehen.
Und jetzt mithilfe des Spritzbeutels
ganz vorsichtig die Creme einfüllen.
Erst mal hinten ausstopfen
und dann ruhig nach vorne ein bisschen verlängern.
Jetzt nehme ich noch frische Erdbeeren dazu.
Dann gehackte Pistazien noch drüber.
Und, wenn ihr möchtet,
noch gerne den Sirup darüberlaufen lassen,
nur ein bisschen davon.
[Musik]
Für den Kuchenteig brauche ich
vier Eier,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
200 Gramm Zucker,
jeweils 200 Milliliter Milch oder Buttermilch.
Hier habe ich noch 200 Milliliter Öl,
ein Päckchen Backpulver,
50 Gramm Kakaopulver
und 250 Gramm Mehl.
Ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die Eier
wie bei einem Rührölteig
und gebe die in eine große Schüssel.
Das Ganze könnt ihr jetzt mit dem Handrührgerät
oder auch mit der Küchenmaschine zubereiten.
Da kommt Vanilleextrakt mit rein,
eine Prise Salz
und der Zucker.
Und die Mischung wird dann
für etwa vier bis fünf Minuten cremig verrührt.
Wenn die Eiermasse dann schön cremig ist,
so wie hier,
kommen jetzt die Flüssigkeiten mit dazu.
Als Nächstes kann ich jetzt die trockenen Zutaten dazu sieben,
also Mehl, Kakao und Backpulver.
Und die werden jetzt auch kurz eingerührt.
Den Teig fülle ich jetzt in meine Backform ein.
Die habe ich bereits gefettet und auch bemehlt,
damit der Kuchen später
einfach wieder ganz leicht rauskommt.
Und so kommt der Teig jetzt in den vorgeheizten Backofen
bei 170°C Ober-/Unterhitze für etwa 20 bis 25 Minuten.
[Musik]
Beide Kuchenteige dürfen nach dem Backen
etwa zehn Minuten abkühlen.
Jetzt werde ich ihn rausstürzen.
Damit jetzt der Kuchen aber nicht an dem Tuch klebt,
könnt ihr jetzt zum Beispiel Zucker drüberstreuen.
Damit das Ganze aber nicht zu süß wird,
nehme ich einfach Bäckerstärke.
Und jetzt den Kuchen rausstürzen.
Und, während der Kuchen abkühlt,
kann ich schon mal die Füllung zubereiten.
Und zwar kommt da eine Art Pudding rein.
Für das Muhallebi brauche ich
800 Milliliter Milch,
50 Gramm Zucker,
60 Gramm Stärke,
– das ist jetzt Maisstärke –
einen Esslöffel Reisstärke
und etwas Vanilleextrakt.
Jetzt nehme ich die Milch.
Und der größte Teil der Milch kommt jetzt in einen Topf
und einen Teil der Milch verrühre ich jetzt mit der Stärke.
Das heißt, ich habe jetzt hier die Maisstärke
und da kommt noch die Reisstärke dazu.
Da kommt die restliche Milch mit rein.
Und da kann ich das schon mal glatt rühren.
Zur Milch im Topf gebe ich jetzt noch den Zucker mit rein
und auch Vanilleextrakt.
Und da könnt ihr jetzt auch gerne
ein bis zwei Teelöffel nehmen.
Das Ganze soll wirklich intensiv nach Vanille schmecken.
Und, sobald die Milch kocht,
nehme ich sie auch sofort vom Herd herunter,
damit sie nicht überkocht,
rühre hier die Stärkemischung ein.
Und dann kommt der Topf gleich wieder auf den Herd drauf
und ich lasse die Mischung dann nur noch kurz aufkochen.
Jetzt erkennt ihr vielleicht schon,
dass die Konsistenz auch ein bisschen anders ist.
Das wird auch superschnell fest.
Damit es schneller abkühlt,
fülle ich das jetzt hier um.
Und, damit sich keine Haut auf der Oberfläche bildet,
werde ich das Ganze jetzt mit Frischhaltefolie abdecken
und dann abkühlen lassen.
Beide Kuchenhälften sind jetzt abgekühlt
und der Pudding, der ist noch so ein bisschen lauwarm.
Aber das ist auch völlig okay so.
Jetzt nehme ich die Folie weg
und kann das Ganze jetzt
mit dem Schneebesen noch ein bisschen glatt rühren.
Die Masse fülle ich jetzt in einen Spritzbeutel.
Da habe ich eine Lochtülle vorne drin.
Und jetzt kann ich die Vertiefungen damit befüllen.
Und jetzt kommt der Deckel dran.
Und zwar
nehme ich jetzt die Seite,
wo ich vorhin ein bisschen was abgerissen habe,
nehme das als Unterseite.
Das heißt, ich stürze das jetzt auf einem Tortenretter.
Und das kann ich jetzt mithilfe des Tortenretters
hier drauf setzen.
Der Kuchen muss jetzt in den Kühlschrank
für etwa eine Stunde.
Und nach dieser Stunde
werde ich den Schokoguss zubereiten.
Und dann kann nämlich schon serviert werden.
Für den Schokoladenguss brauche ich
insgesamt 200 Milliliter Flüssigkeit.
Ich habe jetzt hier zwei Espresso. Das sind 80 Milliliter.
Und den Rest fülle ich mit 120 Millilitern Milch auf.
80 Gramm Puderzucker,
20 Gramm Kakaopulver
und 100 Gramm Herrenschokolade.
Jetzt nehme ich zuerst einmal die beiden Flüssigkeiten.
Die kommen in den Topf.
Da kommt jetzt Puderzucker mit dazu
und Kakao.
Und jetzt muss die Mischung einmal aufgekocht werden.
Und dann noch die Schokolade einrühren.
Die Soße ist jetzt gut verrührt.
Die lasse ich jetzt abkühlen
und werde sie dann auch gleich umfüllen.
Und dann kann ich sie kurz vor dem Servieren
über die Tortenstücke gießen.
[Musik]